on the 19th of August 2023 passed away
John Edward Warnock computer scientist
co-founder of Adobe Systems and author
of the file format very popular with
hackers in the spring of 1991 Warnock
outlined a system called Camelot that
evolved into the portable document
format PDF the aim of PDF was to enable
documents containing text Graphics forms
and links to be created for many
applications and to be viewed and
printed on any machine PDF files have a
very complex structure and it can
contain executable scripts internal
commands and embedded objects this is
often used by attackers to introduce
exploits into PDF documents according to
antivirus companies infected PDF files
still take up a significant amount in
email traffic
and Trend Micro rated malicious PDF on
third place be safe and be aware of PDF
it's convenient but very dangerous
foreign